the lord of the rings the rings of power
finally has its first trailer but if you
don't know your numenor from your
valinor you might be wondering what
exactly is going on wanna know why an
elf would go ice climbing keep watching
to find out
the island nation of numenor is a pretty
big deal during the second age the era
of middle-earth history that the rings
of power will primarily be covering it's
a powerhouse nation of men that
functions as one of the premier
political powers during the era of
sauron's first return its kings are
descended from elrond's twin brother
elros a royal lineage that ultimately
gives aragorn his claim to the throne of
gondor the room has reached
the heart of nouveno still lives
that said very little of the show's new
menorah has been revealed until now that
is in the opening shot of the rings of
power a ship can be seen sailing into a
splendid porch that might remind you of
the architecture of gondor there is a
massive statue to the left side of the
frame recalling the argonauth from the
lord of the rings which was also built
by the numenoreans at a much later date
additionally there's a single mighty
mountain in the distant background this
scene is almost certainly the numenorean
harbor of romana it isn't the capital of
the nation but it's still a critical
location in the story this is the
primary stronghold of the faithful a
group of men who play a key role in the
history of numenor and the foundation of
gondor for one thing it's the home of
aseador the man who eventually cuts the
one ring from sauron's hand if this
really is romana then the mountain in
the background would be the menol tarma
the holy mountain that stood at the
center of the star-shaped island of
numenor while we've known for a while
that numenor will play a central role in
the show seeing the first glimpse of the
majestic sea nation is sure to send a
thrill up any fan's spine
when amazon prime released its first
image from the rings of power way back
in august 2021 it came as a shock to
many die hard fans the jaw-dropping
picture shows the two trees of valinor
monuments of ancient wonder that ceased
to exist long before the second age this
left many people wondering when in
middle-earth history this show is
supposed to take place while we know
that the central plot will follow a
condensed second age timeline it's
entirely possible that the show could go
back even further in the first official
trailer for the rings of power we get
yet another hint that we're going to see
some more of galadriel's backstory in
the first half of the trailer a couple
of scenes feature a majestic yet
dangerous looking frozen landscape one
even sees galadriel jump across an icy
cliff securing herself to the frozen
precipice using her gold and silver
dagger some have floated the idea that
this ice climbing sequence could be
taking place during the flight of the
noldor from the blessed realm which
required them to cross a deadly area of
bitterly frozen land called the
helkoraxa but according to a preview of
the rings of power and vanity fair the
sequence actually shows galadriel in the
foreign waith also known as the northern
waste during a mission to hunt down and
destroy remnants of the original dark
lord morgoth and his missing lieutenant
sauron
[Music]
wandering traveling and generally moving
from one place to the next is a big
theme in both the hobbit and the lord of
the rings one of the finest moments in
tolkien's works appears in a poem about
strider in the fellowship of the ring
which features the iconic line not all
those who wander are lost it appears
that amazon studios has embraced this
concept on every level in the trailer
for the rings of power for example you
might have spotted a pair of strange men
carrying massive antlers fans were
alerted to these characters in vanity
fair's recent behind the scenes report
as nomadic hunters wandering the fields
of middle-earth you'll also have heard a
youngster talking about the many wonders
of the wider world further in we see
glimpses of what very well could be lots
of far-flung areas of the map many of
which are completely new to fans of the
cinematic adaptations of j.r.r tolkien's
works these include the elven kingdom of
lindon as well as a quick shot of a
chained man attacking what looks like a
structure from the southlands if ever
there were any doubt that the amazon
series will take audiences to every
corner of middle-earth well here's the
proof
the beginning of the second age comes
after one of the most momentous events
in all of middle earth's long and
melodramatic history the war of wrath
this literally earth-shattering battle
is the final conflict that takes place
against the first dark lord morgoth in
the end the enemy is defeated and his
servants are either captured killed or
like sauron flee into parts unknown
while the war itself is no doubt epic
the fallout from the event is
straight-up apocalyptic once the
fighting is over an entire portion of
the continent of middle earth sinks
below the waves in a cataclysmic ending
to the first age valerian the region of
middle-earth in which most of the events
of the first stage takes place is
drowned out over the course of a few
years this leads to a number of mass
migrations and while tolkien doesn't go
into a lot of detail it's likely a
stressful time for many of the peoples
of middle earth halfway through the
rings of power trailer you can see a
massive surge of water tossing a tiny
raft around carrying galadriel and the
original character hal brand while it'll
be interesting to see where these
characters end up during the narrative
it's hard not to wonder if this scene is
a glimpse into some of the chaotic
destruction that ushers in the show's
second age setting of course how this
storm might play into the story remains
a mystery and fans will have to wait
until the premiere of the ranks of power
on september 2nd 2022 to find out i
think i'm
quite ready for another adventure
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]